hello everyone so what i'd like to do
here is talk about curvature
curvature
and i've drawn on the xy plane here a
certain curve so this is our x-axis this
is our y-axis this is a curve running
through space and i'd like you to
imagine that this is a road of some kind
and you're driving on it and you're at a
certain point so let's say this point
right here
and if you imagine
what it feels like to drive along this
road and where you need to have your
steering wheel you're turning it a
little bit to the right not a lot
because it's kind of a gentle curve at
this point you're not curving a lot but
the steering wheel isn't straight you
are still turning on the road
and now imagine that your steering wheel
stuck that it's not going to move and
however you're turning it you're stuck
in that situation what's going to happen
hopefully you're on an open field or
something because your car is going to
trace out some kind of circle
right
you know your steering wheel can't do
anything different you're just turning
at a certain
a certain rate
and that's going to have you tracing out
some giant circle and this depends on
where you are right if you had been at a
different point on the curve where the
curve was rotating a lot let's say you
were
back a little bit towards the start at
the start here you have to turn the
steering wheel to the right but you're
turning it much more sharply to stay on
uh
much more sharply to stay on this part
of the curve than you were to be on this
relatively straight part
and the circle that you draw as a result
is much smaller
and this turns out to be a pretty nice
way to think about a measure for just
how much the curve actually curves and
one way you could do this is you can
think okay what is the radius of that
circle the circle that you would trace
out if your steering wheel locked at any
given point and if you kind of follow
the point
along different parts of the curve and
see oh what's what's the different
circle that my car would trace out if it
was stuck at that point you get circles
of varying different radii
right and this radius actually has a
very special name
i'll call this r
this is called the radius of curvature
and you can kind of see how this is a
good way to describe
how much you're turning
radius of curvature you know you may
have um heard with the card descriptions
of the turning radius you know if you
have a car with a very good turning
radius it's very small because what that
means is if you turned it all the way
you could trace out just a very small
circle but a car with a bad turning
radius you know you don't turn very much
at all so you'd have to trace out a much
larger circle
and
curvature itself isn't this r it's not
the radius of curvature but what it is
is it's the reciprocal of that
one over r and there's a um there's a
special symbol for it it's kind of a k
and i'm not sure in handwriting how i'm
going to distinguish it from an actual k
maybe give it a little curly there
it's the greek letter kappa and this is
curvature and i want you to think for a
second why you know why we would take
one over r r is a perfectly fine
description of how much the road curves
but why is it that you would think one
divided by r instead of r itself
and the reason basically is you want
curvature to be a measure of how much it
curves in the sense that more sharp
turns should give you a higher number so
if you're at a point
where you're turning the steering wheel
a lot
you want that to result in a much higher
number but radius of curvature will be
really small when you're turning it a
lot but if you're at a point that's
basically like a straight road you know
there's some slight curve to it but it's
basically a straight road you want the
curvature to be a very small number but
in this case the radius of curvature is
very large so it's really helpful to
just have one divided by r as the
the measure of how much the road is
turning
and in the next video i'm going to go
ahead and start describing a little bit
more mathematically how we capture this
value because as a as a loose
description if you're just kind of
drawing pictures it's perfectly fine to
say oh yeah you imagine a circle that's
kind of closely hugging the curve it's
what your steering wheel would do if you
were locked but in math we will describe
this curve parametrically it'll be the
output of a certain vector-valued
function and i want to know how you can
capture this idea this one over r
curvature idea in a certain formula and
that's what the next few next few videos
are going to cover